- JAHARI, MY FRIEND.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BEAUTIFUL
WOMEN OUT HERE TODAY.
[chuckles]
- YEAH.
KAREEN, MY FRIEND,
YOU SPEAK THE TRUTH.
- WELL, I DO WHAT I CAN.
- OOH.
- OH...
WOW.
- RIGHT?
- HA-HA.
- BLIP.
- SHA-BLOIMPS.
- [laughs]
- YOU KNOW, I CAUGHT A LITTLE
GLIMPSE OF HER FOOT NUT.
[clicks tongue]
- YOU SAW ANKLE BONE?
- WELL...
- GOT SOME ANKLE CLEAVAGE,
YOU DIRTY DEVIL, HUH?
YOU SAW?
- GOD, I SAW.
[both talking over each other]
- YES, KAREEN.
[laughs]
- HEH...
- VERY TASTY...
- EH...
- MM.
- HMM-HMM.
- OH...
- DUDE, DID YOU SEE
THE BRIDGE ON THAT NOSE?
- I MEAN, IF IT IS
ANY INDICATION...
- WOW.
- HHH-HOLY GARBANZO BEANS.
- I'LL TELL YOU WHAT.
THAT IS A BRIDGE
I'D LIKE TO CROSS.
[both laugh]
- THIS IS MY BOY.
THIS IS MY BOY.
- [laughing]
- THIS IS MY BOY.
OH.
- HMM.
- NOT A LOT TO GO ON THERE.
- NOT REALLY. NOT REALLY.
GOOD HEIGHT.
- GOOD HEIGHT.
- CRAZY TALL.
- [growls]
YEAH, LIKE 5'9".
HEH...
- COME ON. COME ON. COME ON.
- [muttering]
- COME ON. SHE'S TALL.
SHE'S TALL. SHE'S TALL.
- THAT'S RIGHT. SHE'S TALL.
THERE'S NOTHING TO BE DONE.
- GETTING WET. LET ME SEE--
LET ME SEE IT FROM BEHIND.
THAT'S HOW YOU HIT IT.
- JAHARI,
CAN I TELL YOU SOMETHING
IN CONFIDENCE RIGHT NOW?
- OKAY.
- [whispers]
I'M A VIRGIN.